[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Logans in
Lexington Kentucky hi Logan how are you
good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up Hey so uh real fast
I'll give you a backstory of where I'm
at today um uh April of 22 U my wife and
I got married um before we got married I
had about $30,000 in uh my bank account
uh she had uh $5,000 student loan and uh
$177,000 car note um pretty much as soon
as we got married paid that off got that
out Al took care of um we then um rented
an apartment for a year and uh decided
we were going to stay there um until we
had enough money to put a good down
payment on a house um unfortunately
after that year um we had an opportunity
uh present itself to buy a home from a
family friend at a pretty well
discounted price well below what the
home value was um we knew that it was
too much house for us it's a 4200 ft
house
$315,000 is what we paid for it um
firsttime home buyer so we didn't have
any money to put down 0% Downs what we
got um 6.25% interest rate um we knew it
was going to be a lot but we tried
anyway uh we live there up until
November of this past year barely making
it living paycheck to paycheck um
struggling our manager struggling we
just decided we can't do this anymore if
if we want this to work and we do um so
we end up putting the house up for sale
um sold the house in seven days um for
$415,000 so $100,000 more than we gave
for it in
March um after realtor fees etc etc we
uh walked away with
$77,000 um within the time that we lived
in the home we accumulated $10,000 with
a credit card at updating the home um it
was built in 2002 so it was very
outdated and to try to get that uh home
value up even more to sell it we put
$10,000 on a credit card via you know
furniture for us and then fencing and
new flooring etc etc um today um I have
right at $50,000 in the bank $22,000 of
that 77 I bought my wife a car um we
just found out in Christmas that on
Christmas day that she's pregnant do her
first baby um I'm 26 she's
25 um I have a car note for $37,500 what
I owe on it um so now we have three
vehicles two are paid off one truck that
I have is not paid off 37,500 what I owe
on it um the reason what are you smoking
that you go buy a $37,000 car after you
just sold a house because you couldn't
breathe no it was 22,000 is what I paid
for her car I already had the $37,000
car Lo what do you guys make a
year uh 130 together good
Lord okay yeah like I said I've had the
what can I do help got ticket dude and
you blew your nose in it that's what you
did man what can you what
can how come you got $50,000 in the bank
after you sell both cars and pay your
capital gains you're probably
even right yeah that's the thing I don't
know how much the capital gain
percentage is um it's it's not it's not
a capital gain it's ordinary income cuz
you didn't hold that house a year so
it's a it's a 35% tax on the actual gain
and the gain is not 415 the gain is
after sales expenses and you probably
did some Capital Improvements on that
credit card debt that you can deduct as
well so you probably have a $70,000 gain
at 35% probably got a $20,000 tax bill
you need to sit down with a tax person
and figure out what that is but it's
probably right around there and you have
cars you can't afford and you went and
bought another one
right go sell both of
them okay and you're not going to are
you no I I I I will I'm thinking what
I'm thinking is you know we live an hour
from work both of us we live grantree
now on her grandparents estate
Unfortunately they passed away they had
a house here they didn't want to sell so
we're living here rentree um so what
does that mean you have to be stupid
with
cars no it free doesn't describe stupid
cars right right so we're just trying to
decide should I sell my truck yes yes
you know get okay that's I'm you should
sell the car you just bought
her okay y'all are broke people
man yeah you're broke you make $130,000
a year and you've made a series of bad
financial decisions that have caused you
to be broke the best way to do it is go
back to the last time you were standing
on Solid Ground which is when you had a
couple of junky cars that were paid for
and $100,000 cash in the bank yeah that
was a while back but yeah yeah get let's
get rid of both of these get the most
get the best car you can get for cash no
and figure out what your capital gains
are so the $222,000 car you bought her
did you use the $50,000 cash to do that
or did you go get a loan on that no no
no we we had 77,000 in the bank oh so
now you got 50 after buying that car so
that car is paid for yeah both we have
two cars that are paid for and one car
that one truck my truck is not both of
our cars are paid for oh good then just
get rid of the truck get rid of the
truck and pay the capital
gains right that that was my main
question yeah okay I'm caught up with
you now yeah but dude you got to quit
buying crap you don't go buy a $22,000
car when you walk out of this disaster
you just came from it literally I mean
it's the exact conversation you just had
about breaking the cycle you do you like
we can't breathe we got to s house we
sold the house hey we got some money
let's go buy let's go buy a car let's
buy a car oh let's get pregnant and then
buy another car and it's like oh I can't
breathe again well what are we going to
do now I got to sell the car and do this
and do this hey we got some more money
let's go get a yeah it's like thank God
it's Friday oh God it's Monday yeah
we're in this rentree house well you
know it's got to have new floors and a
new roof and a new this let's put on the
credit card we'll just pay it off later
we don't even have a house payment I
think you could be dead free if you sell
the truck mhm and pay your capital gains
and pay off the credit card and chop
them up and then you're going to have to
make a decision to never do the stupid
crap you've been doing for the past 3
years you have to do man when I went
broke Logan I was your age and I had to
sit down and do an autopsy a CSI on Dave
and I looked at all the stupid butt
stuff Dave was doing and had to go if
you want to live like this you can keep
doing the stupid butt stuff or I can
stop doing the stupid butt stuff and
have a better life and that's why I'm
yelling at you cuz I love you I want you
to win dude create your free everyday
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life